[Music]
no more
[Music]
barry allen
bruce wayne
you said that like it explains why
there's a total stranger in my place
sitting in the dark in my second
favorite chair
tell me about this
this is a person who looks exactly like
me but who is definitely not me
very attractive jewish boy
somebody who i don't know stole your
pocket watch or
railroads
i know you have abilities
i just don't know what they are
my special skills include viola web
design fluent in sign language gorilla
sign language silica based quartz sand
fabric abrasion resistant heat resistant
uh yeah i do competitive ice dancing
what they use on the space shuttle to
prevent it from burning up on re-entry i
do
very competitive ice dancing
whoever you're looking for
it's not
[Music]
[Music]
he's a batman
so you're fast
that feels like an oversimplification
i'm putting together a team
people with special abilities
you see i believe enemies are coming
stop right there
i'm in
you are
yeah i
i need friends
people are
difficult they require a lot of focus
they uh they have like a rhythm that i
haven't quite been able to
like brunch like
what is brunch
you wait in line for an hour for
essentially lunch
i mean
i don't know
people are a little slow
i'll try to keep up
can i keep this
it's like this layer of dimensional
reality and it seems to manipulate
space-time i call it the speed force it
causes me to burn a tremendous amount of
calories so i am just a black hole of
snacks i am a snack hole
how many people are on this special
fight team
three including you three against what
i'll tell you on the plane
wait
what are your superpowers again
i'm rich
you